[موسيقى]
انا عليه السند فنانه اماراتيه متخصصه في
مجال التصوير
[موسيقى]
والخط الفتره انا كنت اصور تصوير
فوتوغرافي واعرض وبعدين بحكم العمل اضطريت
اني اوقف فتره وق اكتشفت ان عندي موهبه
الخط
وافتقدت التصوير نفسه فكنت ابحث عن شيء
تقنيه اقدر استخدم فيها الاثنين فيوم شفت
التصوير باستخدام الضوء عجبني الموضوع
تقنيه التصوير باستخدام الضوء تقنيه مو
جديده اللي هي اللونج اكسبوجر بس طبعا
تطورت من هذيك الفتره يلين يومنا هذا في
ناس بدوا يصورون يرسمون باستخدام الضوء
اللي هو اللايت بينتين وفي ناس حولتها
للخط الخط الاجنبي
والخط
العربي احنا عننا بالعربي نكتب من اليمين
لين اليسار بس عشان استخدام الكاميرا عشان
يطلع لنا صح نكتب من اليسار لين اليمين
تقدر انت يعني تعكس الصوره حد يقوللي ليش
ما تعكسي الصوره لا جمالها في انها تكون
نفس ما هي الادت يكون شيء بسيط عليها من
الاعمال المحببه لي لوحه حياه التراب نفسه
الشير نفسه هذا مكاني هذا وطني فهو اللي
فيه انا احيا عشان شي سميتها
حياه
نصيحتي للمراه اذا عندها حلم تبغي تحققه
لا تنتظر بالمثابره والشغل واذا عندك شغف
للشيء فتوصل وين ما تبي
توصل